[Music]
i'm sonic a little ball of super energy
in an extremely handsome package on my
planet people were always after my
powers
so i came to yours it gets a little
lonely
but that's okay i am living my best life
on earth
oh at the place sonic
at the bridges mountain also sunny
ugh i can't with that guy
oh uh
why are you hiding out in my garage
they're coming for me if they steal my
power they could conquer the universe
you have to help me no i don't please
it's life or death good morning my rural
chum
i'm going to give you five seconds to
tell me where it is
wait don't hurt him
road trip this can't be happening to me
oh my god stop the car right now what
the world's largest rubber band ball
we gotta see it no this is not some fun
family road trip
eh you're right it was lame gift shop
was cool though
[Music]
whatever this creature is i'm going to
uncover the source of its power
[Music]
i just thought you might like a latte
with steamed austrian goat milk of
course i want a latte
i love the way you make them we gotta
lay low
let me show you how it's done
so should we get out of here yeah time
to go i always want to do this
nailed it
how are you not dead i have no idea oh
give me a big fat threat
that was an illegal left by the way oh
this one is cute let's keep him
oh come on you've got car insurance
right
why would you throw your life away for
this silly little alien
good time he's my friend let's go
[Applause]
this is my power and i'm using it to
protect
my friends
so you're supposed to be tom's best
friend that he won't shut up about
well i don't see the appeal that is very
gross
let's go
[Music]
you